[Music]
hello everybody R what's up wait a
minute three girls one wife something is
missing this guy there's my
boys I know you love your D go out say
it d d y of course he loves you he just
he just doesn't show it on his face or
with his body language right crew Junior
come
on gr I need a word with you your
family's lives are at stake
what Maxim raal has escaped from pison
I'm coming for my revenge
group we have to get to the safe house
it has
a I love this place
look the most important part of a heist
is being aware of potential
dangers I Tred
[Music]
myself oh here
she watch out watch out watch out watch
out
no
what
imprudent
thanks
Ron fire in
the